blog mas giorno 9 assist e giocate
questo mattino allora ti spiego perché
tipo questo tipo il quadrante normale
che fosse il carino sì però ho bisogno
di più personalità per me uno è questo
che mi fa molto ridere ti faccio vedere
pare che costruiti crescono i baffi
carino e poi st pollo picco li tolgo su
chi mi fa molto ridere ma ce n'è un
altro 188 passi in troppi non fate
l'altro procura di torino che ha
acquisito è molto tenero chiude gli
occhi le apre la loro bottino si google
mi racconti una barzelletta
penso ad essere una persona piedi per
terra almeno grazie alla forza di
gravità
google mi racconti un'altra barzelletta
erano cinque nella sera le cinque della
sera alle cinque della sera sul roll o
joe fermo qualcosa possiamo fare oggi
opta per una domenica facciamo quello
che ci dice però abbiamo come proposta
creare lo stone orte in casa abbiamo già
fatto un albero ieri grazie
come sai siamo fatto a rimettervi in
moto una corsetta ha già fatto 188 bassi
mi sono rimesso in moto o organizzare in
parti si sa cosa dovremmo fare
e te le dico alla mia famiglia di
rivederci il prossimo ovviamente una
cena
più che un parte quindi loro penseranno
loro perfetto rinnovare il guardaroba
pane per i miei denti questa potremmo
andare a cercare il marioni di natale
attivo assurdo
io e lui stiamo andando a porta di roma
per prendere il maglione abbiamo deciso
però di fare una sfida la sfida la
seguente prenderemo lo stesso maglione
in modo che abbiamo quasi identica e a
quel punto io dovrò fare il meglio da
lui e lui dovrà fare il maglione o meno
questo sa cosa vuol dire cosa non
ridicolo sembrerà in un cassonetto
la discarica sembrerai nataletti michael
bublè di mariah carey non è di nessun
altro
jamie spedizione terminata siamo tornati
a casa
abbiamo preso dai cinema due maglioni
c'era solamente panna perché non c'erano
tipo né rosso né verde quindi dovremo
comunque avere anche una base un
canovaccio un pochino più arduo ci
stavano così almeno di colori vengono
fuori squadra siamo dici tu io sono tony
quindi al posto questo sarà il tuo che
mi prendo io
scusate l'obiettivo è quello è il mio
che ti prendi tu bene in bocca al lupo
così come abbiamo fatto tipo 200.000
cose in questi giorni possiamo fare non
fare niente oggi ho proprio niente non
voglio fare niente tv netflix betclic
tipo cliccato indietro colloquio netflix
amazon pride
alla fine con lui abbiamo deciso di
vederci come che si chiama
[Musica]
principesse
si aspetta che così non capisce che
arriviamo un pochino questo baby come se
curioso
lo scopo è molto curioso e molto
natalizio
lo dobbiamo andare a cena dei miei
fratelli
beh ho sonno
benvenuti in questo episodio di
sono tutti di là e noi stiamo preparando
la cena siamo scesi per prendere due
stronzate alla fine finirà così siamo
tornati col bottino e non sanno cosa
stiamo preparando bene ma il primo
episodio di in cucina con il super
scilla prossimi abbiamo dei bellissimi
cubetti orata fresi mamma mia non potete
sentire l'odore ma ragazzi credetemi
animare puro ci sia una nota proverò la
mia il mio classico piatto perché noi
siamo famosi per le tartare e proverò a
fare una tartare cioè proverò già so che
viene abbiamo ben pensato di prendere
due chili e mezzo di connors parte che
poi vogliono tentare distorcersi
informazioni sul cibo su chi vuoi che ti
serve un variabile che la partita viva
la fine serve fuori ma scusa adesso se
tu importi coi dati ci stanno pure i
video di adesso non li prendo e chi me
lo dice ci sono tutti gli ingredienti là
dentro
è vero se vuoi essere complice degli
ingredienti fare il vago proveremo a
fare questo esperimento
fuori nonna che succede fuori
ricordate sempre che la tartara di
taglia a coltello non fate frullati oro
basteranno quali sono toccate di skele
rossa del pesce vascolare stata inserire
una nuova distanti l'uomo fa i nuovi
perché veramente non procuri un pò al
solito sono cercate van acker caruccia
una cosa così invisibile presa la fine
sbuca fuori non lovino tutte le sorprese
io vado avanti e incastrato qui davanti
a un cosa c'è su monito che cosa essi
quadro e ci ha capito non lo so ma sa
che gli sbirri cento quell'essere
complice la dopo per prendere i gamberi
per lui abbiamo una tartare ho fatto da
gabriele una pasta una pasta a cura di
gianluigi casa calda cosa che ci avete
appena se le vittorie tartare servizio
pessimo mi sono dimenticato di mettere
la russa che schifo
pessimo perché mi hanno pagato gabriele
posso cabret ci puoi descrivere il
piatto di gatta e sono quelli caso
enrico perché schizzinoso quindi sono
puliti i suoi privati e ora fatto questa
battuta simpatica cretino usando del
pazzo intanto come titolo organi di atti
con nuovo cup vinta che non si sente
perché in preparazione con i sonohra ma
slime come servito su una base di
carasau software adattare super
indicante cos'è una calata con un catino
battuto di polipo e cubetti di orata di
spietata eccolo lì e il poster di un
film che ho fatto che mia nonna si
chiede sopra il televisore perché
imbarazzo per me vederlo ragazzi c'è ma
per noi ne dici che stai ma dove stai
non si fa di dieci un regalo ai telefoni
io mi sono stancato di aspettare ragazzi
alla mia mamma
ma non è giusto ma perché l'energia così
tanta andare subito a tante questa pasta
perché lui non mangiavo il cane abbiamo
fatto la pasta che mai ci servirà al
governo
tutto è stato fatto in funzione di luigi
questa bastava scrivo per colpa tua
allora alla morte di questa pasta e
aggiungere questo olio che hanno fatto
con cos'è com'è che si chiama che l'uomo
caro anni è un peperoncino che
teoricamente si fida che cos'è la
capsicina è un componente che il
componente della della picca altezza
acqua che non ti riesce a mettere a
fuoco manco grandezza voi siete la morte
sua e non ti fa pesare il fatto che non
c'è il gambero repressione tu non mi
devi parlare
manca in questa tappa al rimorso e che
non morde guarda quante cose universo sì
no no perché non nonna ma scusa ma
perché non bisogna fare
si mettono le vetrate tutto lei è
convinta che ci sia una testa qua dietro
c'è se io ascolto c'è una testa non c'è
in nuce una senso morto oggi a questo
canale è diventato il trash del web zona
prevederebbe in cava che motivo non
mischiato col sorbello prima la cipolla
vero k non è piaciuta la cipolla ha
elogiato 9 sono miei amici di commento a
caldo su questa cena la vostra
buonissima ha detto rometti
cari compagni si sta permettendo di
tutto ma che tu che fai
82 del tar ecco chi ha fatto guarda che
ti sono vicini che sta ridendo dove chi
sta ridendo era l'architetto mio
fratello ha chiesto quali erano le
parolacce usate cribbio miei ragazzi
valentine
[Applauso]
[Risate]
si è chiuso in imbarazzo in questa grave
ritardo l aspetta c'è una testa quasi in
una testa sotto non ha fatto quando dice
che c'è nella testa non c'è una persona
alla testa io non capisco tg al a muro
[Applauso]
[Risate]
ricordi sono ritornati dovuto chiamare
abbiamo perso ma cosa ma il motivo
perché è accaduto sulla ram e metterci
[Musica]
[Risate]
ricovero male pensa uno strumento più
opportuno
posso capire questa squadra
eliminati
[Musica]
guarda molto sul bando siccome non
potresti mi sono comprato queste
bacchette cinesi tra tiger
accompagnato lui stazione adesso dopo la
mangiata quindi magnata salirà a milano
carico come un uovo mentre tornerò a
casa a carico di tristezza e desolazione
e con questa e con questa nota così
allegra chiudiamo questo blog ci vediamo
domani con un altro blocco ma se le 14
ciao